foreign
Dylan is with us in Salt Lake City hi
Dylan how are you
good how are you Dave thank you for
taking my call my pleasure what's up
so my wife and I have been married for
three years ago or for three years now
we've been going to school or going to
college she graduated this past May with
an engineering degree and I graduate
this upcoming May with an engineering
degree
we're 100 debt free we made it through
college
with no student loans
and we've been able to save about sixty
thousand dollars that we've earmarked
for a home
and we're curious as to whether or not
now is the time to buy with interest
rates so high and with with just
everything going on in the market
uncertainty
um yeah so what's your what's your
advice for me or other questions you
have
you're gonna you know you're gonna stay
in that area
yes we are
okay so you get um
I mean you get out of school and you're
gonna take a job and that's not going to
change the real estate decision
yes okay all right
I mean I can believe that I just wanted
to double check and you have zero debt
of any kind of 60 grand for a down
payment
zero debt of any kind 60 grand for a
down payment and about 30 000 in
retirement accounts and two years funded
HSA account good for you okay
well done well done okay uh I would buy
now
uh regardless of interest rates uh
here's what I don't know
uh 12 to 24 months from now I don't know
what interest rates will be
I do know house prices will have gone up
seven to eight percent a year during
those that time
okay house prices are continuing to go
up and pre and and uh regardless of
interest rates because there continues
to be a shortage of housing versus the
number of buyers looking
now so the in other words the strategy
is we can predict that the cost is going
to go up so we might as well get in now
we don't know if rates are going to go
down or not so waiting on them to come
down they might not
yeah
there's no guarantee they're going to
come down
yeah um and uh they they sat at six for
a decade
before and then in 2008 they were
artificially driven down because of the
housing crisis and the government just
straight up manipulated the market and
drove the rates all the way down to
about one percent there for a minute and
then up to two then up to three and then
back down to two and a half and then up
to three and it sat there for a while
and and then jumped up just recently you
know to six and seven again and uh
everybody's freaking out like that's a
high interest rate but over the scope of
History it's not really a high interest
rate so what I would say is this we know
house prices are going to go up so let's
buy if interest rates go down which we
don't know you can always refinance
you're not stuck but you are stuck with
house prices
yeah so bye now
okay another question for you is in that
case say we we buy in the next six
months how much house can we afford our
income last year was about 80 80k we
have a baby on the way doing due early
next year so my wife won't be working as
much
um but when the baby comes in I'll be
working full time so that's kind of the
projected income is about 80k a year
yeah a fourth of your take-home pay on a
15-year fixed rate mortgage is our
suggestion
and that's going to mean you're probably
going to buy less house than you thought
you were going to buy before this call
but that's okay it's your first house
you're in your early 20s you got time
you're both Engineers you're both
working someday you can easily move up
in house later so again I would get into
the game uh the only thing that's now
making me hesitate is I don't know if
I'm going to move a pregnant woman or
third trimester
that sounds like a hell on Earth to me I
don't think I want to do that yeah but
um but you know you might I don't know
uh the further along in the pregnancy
she is the less likely I am to buy until
after the baby
so just because it's you know it's hard
on her I mean really she's got y'all got
enough on your play without dealing with
the hanging curtains for God's sakes so
um yeah it's okay to not buy there's no
sin that says you have to buy
immediately but you know we were
discussing interest rates and prices a
minute ago now we're talking about your
life
so I might wait till after the baby
comes my weight here
uh just just for just for comfort you
know uh there's nothing that says you
have to do it now and you have plenty of
time and you'll both have great careers
you'll both make great incomes you're
going to be debt-free millionaires in
your 30s no matter which of these you do
whether you buy before or after the baby
but a 15-year fixed where the fourth of
your take-home pay is going to the
payment and you'll be right on track get
that house paid off or move up later on
when everybody's back working and all
that kind of stuff and the other thing
too is I think he's short changing
himself as to what their income could be
I know his wife's going to back off a
little bit he'll be coming out into the
market I think it's very possible if
they wait a year that they might find
that their income is is higher yeah
that's very possible
might put you into a different house if
interest rates stay the same and house
prices went up seven percent during that
year which is probably what's going to
happen
um you know the only thing that's really
going to push interest rates down that I
can see today is the fact that we're
going into a presidential election year
and generally the sitting party will try
to drive rates down to say look what I
did that's correct
um and they you know and and we all know
that why weren't you doing that two
years ago then you know I mean it's that
there's always that but
um I I don't I wouldn't hold your breath
because uh Jerome Pal's gone on record
as saying if when we've got this uh
inflation rate where it is and it's
still a little higher than they expected
when when July report came in and so
unemployment's still very very low I
would expect him to raise it a couple
more times they're just screwing with it
just to prove that it's not they're uh
it's a whole other discussion they're
trying to
trying to use a hammer on a Phillips
head screwdriver but they just because
they don't know what the heck they're
doing but the it's a disaster but anyway
all of that to say I don't know that
you're going to see interest rates come
down so you you just decide in the scope
of your life with a baby on the way when
we're gonna buy